نتابع مع عرض اخبار ونتائج الانتخابات
الامريكيه مع تحليل معطياتها والان نفتح
ملفا اخر هو كيف صوتت المجموعات العرقيه
والفئات السنيه المختلفه في الانتخابات
النصفيه الاجابه في استطلاع لوكاله
اسوشيات برس امتدت الفتره الزمنيه
للاستطلاع من الايام التي سبقت الاقتراع
وحتى يوم الاقتراع ذاته وشملت مئه وخمسه
عشر الف شخص ممن صوتوا او ابداوا النيه
لذلك نسبه النساء بين الناخبين كانت اثنين
وخمسين بالمئه مقارنه
باربعه 44% للرجال نصفهن من النساء على
الاقل صوتنا للمرشحين الديمقراطيين اما
بالنسبه للرجال فسوق ثلاثه 53% منهم من ال
44% الجمهوريين ننتقل الى الفئات العمريه
الديمقراطيون نادوا اصواتا اكثر عبر
الفئات العمريه بين ثمانيه عشر عاما وتعا
39 عاما وبفرق كثير نسبيا التقارب بين
الحزبين كان في الفئه العمريه من من هم في
الاربعينات من اعمارهم ليعود الجمهوريون
في التفوق عندما يتعلق الامر بالناخبين من
50 عاما واكثر
[موسيقى]
الان الى التقسيمات العراقيه والاثنيه
57% من الناخبين البيض صوتوا للجمهوريين
على الجانب الاخر 82% من المواطنين من
اصول افريقيه ذهبت اصواتهم للديمقراطيين
اما الناخبون من اصول اللاتينيه فاختاري
ثمانيه من كل عشره منهم مرشحا ديمقراطيا
تصنيف اخر الاستطلاع
كانت التعليم الجمهوريون نالوا اصواتا
اكثر من قبل مؤيديهم الذين حظيوا بجزء من
التعليم الجامعي ولم يكملوه اضافه لحماله
شهاده الثانويه او اقل اخيرا في هذا الجزء
نتحدث عن المجتمعات المحليه سكان المدن
الذين صوتوا بنسبه تجاوزت 60%
للديمقراطيين وتعادل تقريبا النسبه بين
الحزبين بالنسبه لسكان الضواحي والارياف
اما بالنسبه للبلدات الصغيره والمناطق
النائيه
فقد صوت سكانها للجمهوريين بنسب وصلت لضعف
النسبه التي حصل عليها مرشحوا لحزب
الديمقراطي
[موسيقى]
فصلت في استطلاعها ملفات مهمه للناخبين
اثنان من كل ثلاثه ناخبين جمهوريين كان
الملف الاقتصادي يدافعهم للتصويت في مكانه
النسبه
33% عند الناخبين الديمقراطيين التغيير
المناخي والاجهاض ملفان كان لهما مكان
متقدمه عند الديمقراطيين خاصه بسبب ملف
الاجهاض وقرار المحكمه العليا بتقليد
عمليات الاجهاض في الولايات المتحده على
جانب الاخر كان ملف الهجره مهما جدا
للناخبين الجمهوريين ونال اهتمام 87% منهم
لكنه هناك ملفا واحدا حدث فيه التقارب وهو
ملف الجريمه
56% من الجمهوريين اعتبره مهما في حين وصل
الاهتمام بين الديمقراطيين لاربعين في
المئه
اخيرا بعد ان انتهت الانتخابات وبدات
عمليات الفرز باستثناء عمليات الاعاده
طبعا لاحقا هذا السؤال وجه للناخبين هل
تثق بشكل كبير بان الاصوات سيتم عدها بشكل
دقيق
77% من الناخبين الديمقراطيين اجابوا بنعم
وقبل 20% فقط على الطرف المقابل ومن بين
الجمهوريين 55% قالوا انهم وافقونا نسبيا
اخيرا انعدام الثقه الجزئيه او الكلي كان
كبيرا لدى الجمهوريين عندما قال 86% منهم
انهم لا ثقه لهم بالنتائج مقابل 10% فقط
بين الديمقراطيين في كل الاحوال لا يبدو
التشكيك كبيرا في عمليات الاقتراع او
النتائج باستثناء اريزونا و- جورجيا حتى
الان جورجيا التي ستجرى فيها عمليات
الاعاده في السادس من ديسمبر